- [Instructor] One idea
that we're going to keep
coming back to in our study of government
is the notion of public policy
and how public policy is actually made
and what we're gonna do in this video
is focus on what you could consider to be
the five stages of the policy process
and I'll use a very simple example
to make those stages tangible.
So, the first stage of
the public policy process
is identifying issues or agenda-setting,
so agenda.
Agenda-setting right over
here or identifying issues.
An example of that, and
this is actually something
that is going on near my house right now,
is that there is an intersection
about two blocks from my house,
so let me see if I can
draw this intersection.
So, looks something like this
and it's a two-way stop sign,
so you have a stop sign right over there.
You have a stop sign right over there
and the problem is you have
this large park in this corner
right over there and
there's also a school here
and so in the morning there's
a lot of kids and parents
going on their bicycles
or walking to school,
but the problem is there's
also a lot of parents
who might be late for school
and they're going in their cars
and they're going quite
fast down this road
and it's a two-way stop and so even though
there's a lot of kids
that are waiting to cross
right over here, and
there's no crossing guard,
so there's a lot of kids and
parents walking right here,
they have to wait and you can imagine,
this is an elementary school.
These cars are going by really fast.
It's quite dangerous, so
the agenda here is that,
well, how do you make
this safer and easier
for families to cross the
street on the way to the park?
So, the example here.
How to make easier
to cross the street at that intersection?
Now, once you determine the
problem that you want solved,
you do the agenda-setting, the next step
is to formulate some type of a policy,
so I'll call that step
two, would be policy,
policy formulation.
So, one potential idea here is,
well, why don't we just make
this into a four-way stop?
So we could put some paint
here to make it clear
that people are going
to cross on all sides
and we'll put two more stop signs
to make this a four-way stop
and so let's say that
this is our current plan
as we say, hey, we're
making this tangible.
We're going to implement a four-way stop
at that intersection.
Now, that's not the only
solution that's possible.
Maybe some type of speed bumps
might be in order right over
here and right over here.
Maybe they implement some
type of crossing guard
or maybe you put one of
those flashing blinking signs
that tell people their speed limits
so that they go slower, so
there's many different ways
to formulate ideas that
will address this agenda,
that will address these problems,
but let's say that we do a study
and we decide that a four-way stop
is the policy that we want to pursue.
Well, then the next step after that
is to convince other people
that this is a good idea,
so step three right over here
we could call policy, policy adoption.
Adoption or legitimization,
and in my context,
it might involve going to the city council
maybe with some traffic
experts, some safety experts.
Maybe I could go gather
the community here,
petition so that a lot of
people in the community here
agree that a four-way
stop would be in order
and let's say the city council
and the police department
and all the various stakeholders
who have to buy in say,
"Yes, we are going to implement
a four-way stop here."
And then they implement it
and so once the policy is adopted,
the next thing is, well, you've
gotta actually implement it,
so I'll call that step four.
Policy,
policy implementation.
Implementation.
Mentation, and in this case,
it's pretty straightforward.
Someone needs to show up and
install those stop signs.
Maybe they're gonna put
some markers over here
to make it more clear that people
are going to cross the street
as they go on to the park,
but that would be the implementation.
Now, the last step in
this public policy cycle
or this process, and you'll
see it really is a cycle,
is to just assess it, to
evaluate how things are going,
so the next step, we'll call
this step five right over here,
would be policy assessment.
Assessment.
Or evaluation and so one possibility
is to go survey people in the community.
Has that solved the problem?
Has it created new problems?
Is there a traffic issue now
because people have to
go to the four-way stop?
And whatever the assessment says,
the assessment might say, "Hey,
everything's perfect now,"
and then you don't really have to worry
about this problem anymore,
but maybe there's a new traffic problem
and now that'd be another issue to address
and you would have to go
through the cycle again
or maybe it hasn't
addressed the speed issue
and so maybe you need to think about,
well, how do we slow cars
down or whatever else?
And we would keep going through
this public policy process
or this, really this cycle
that we're talking about.
Now, the example that I just gave,
this is a very simple example
at a corner two blocks from my house
and this is actually
something I'm thinking about.
I'm thinking about going to
the city council about this,
but as you can imagine, as
we go into much deeper things
that are affecting people
at the federal level,
healthcare, taxes, whatever else,
each of these steps can be quite involved
and it can even take years
to do any one of these steps.